a few weeks ago afghans had to go
through rigorous security to play
football in the park next to the
governor's house in jalalabad
since the governor handed over control
of the city to the taliban they don't
need permission they say they continue
to play in their kits without any
problem
less than half an hour ago at the same
venue taliban leaders from nangarhar
province were addressing people
most of those in the stadium gathered to
show their support for the taliban
we're very excited after 20 years the
islamic emirate of afghanistan is back
as the former government was
illegitimate now everyone is very happy
and we have a peaceful afghanistan no
one is stopping us from saying anything
on social media
is the provincial capital and it's on a
crucial eastern trade route with
pakistan
taliban leaders are content with their
two-week progress as the focus remains
on security and rooting out corruption
everyone feels secure which has
encouraged them to continue with their
business earlier that wasn't possible
and people used to close their shops
before sunset as they were afraid of
being robbed and killed but now shops
are open till midnight and people are
happy
there was no violence when the taliban
took over but business is slower than
before banks are closed and many people
are concerned about the future they
remember the taliban from 20 years ago
and there are also traders who are
concerned about the dwindling business
prospects in the last two weeks despite
this being a period of security and
safety
shafiola sells a popular local suite
known here as ash
even before the taliban came in
thousands of government employees had
not received their salaries for months
and he's been struggling to attract
customers
we're all happy that there's peace but
we're all concerned about our businesses
as there's hardly any activity people
are suffering the taliban must do
something and should connect with
neighbouring countries to improve trade
even though fewer women venture out
there's relative peace in jalalabad with
its usual traffic jams and loud horns we
asked the taliban why people are scared
of them
they say 60 000 soldiers from this
province have died fighting them in the
last two decades it will take time for
their families to believe that the
taliban are not out for revenge as
jalalabad's new rulers celebrate victory
and work towards establishing a
government people pray these fighters
can also maintain the social and
economic fabric of the city's vibrant
society